mark pliers mini montage huh
or Oh mark you did a good job
whoa like high five like ah like we just
ha ha no no like like [ __ ] what
no high five high faces Oh
Avenue boo um hey I just don't get what
you're saying Lincoln Logs they're not
racist
no pretty cool but Lincoln Logs how are
they racist
well the end then Oh go go go go go go
go yeah yeah yeah yeah okay yeah yeah
tonight I just I'm really worried I
don't like this phase you're going
through it's not a phase dad this is who
I am
Hey nope oh hey I actually wanted to say
something uh you know Matt and I were
talking here you're you're very handsome
man thank you yeah anyway yeah anyway so
just I've been doing lunch that means so
much more coming from an ugly person I
mean thank you yeah I mean yeah no
problem yeah yeah I get you're so ugly
but I'm glad you can recognize like
beauty here Hey hope you enjoyed the
video this was an experiment in two mini
sketches and we've got tons of stupid
ideas through more videos down the road
so if you'd like to see more please
leave a like let us know in the comments
or even leave a suggestion for us to
make a video in the future thanks again
but I